I like how there's a Red Bull hidden in
Troy's couch cushions there's no release
there's a can there's some kind of
there's some kind of illicit well there
is yeah you're not wrong
where show me where show me you're
talking with the pale liar oh it's a
[ __ ] can of nitrous it's still that's
it's not that it's not the it's not the
most intuitive place to store it what is
it you see this this is Oribe super hair
fine hair spray y'all if you thought
about I know exactly what do you think
this is that holds us up willpower come
on guys
all right my regrets come on that's how
he gets the hair so nice I understand
now you always do the Wonder Woman thing
right before you take a picture you're
like oh this and all your hair just like
grows grows more hair and then you take
flawless images of yourself it's a half
lip is it sometimes genuinely yes you
just flip it here never gonna happen for
me we got a title it's called play watch
listen which is in part because we talk
about things that you can play watch or
listen to but also because the thought
was you play games that Mike Biffle game
director makes you watch things that I
write or record and you can listen to
Troy Baker and his beautiful voice in
many video games and Austin wintry and
his lovely composing in many video games
so I thought it worked on multiple
levels I love it I don't love that the
listening has to get diluted into both
Troy and me and you guys each get one of
your own hey this is this is pretty much
I just saw her in I'm just gonna lose
that fight is all I'm saying
yeah man because but we only need one
audio console green eyes coming yes
adios
it's no it's just this credit goes to
you Ilana piers because you are the one
who actually came up with this I believe
right I had stupid ideas you know like
that was one of Troy's titles with the
clips I remember there was a part of
again the New York Comicon genre xpanel
that brought this idea together where
Austin and I afterwards discussed how he
had the same idea for a joke because
Troy you had said something that was
along the lines of I'm not gonna like
peg you down or something like that and
I was like I should have made that joke
do you wanna do it you'll meet it I'll
be yeah we're like we're like Disney
Plus I guess we're committed to at pg-13
max what a segue you like that basically
that's cuz Troy and I decided that even
though last time it was all about Star
Wars and we're resolved to not make this
all about Star Wars we're basically only
gonna talk about Mandalorian now hold on
hold on preface please preface through
preface I am and this is my post face I
am three episodes into it it's great so
I am great chef baby Yoda is is is if
that if I the the current train that I
am on is I have no idea what the time
frame is I don't know if they're going
you know Old Republic like you said
Austin and this is like the thousands of
years are there for years we know what
they they establish what the time frame
is we know what it is all they say he's
not actually baby all they said this is
post Empire right
it's post oh I I didn't hear post Jedi
yet
yeah trilogy yeah it takes place after
Return of the Jedi before force awakens
spoiling [ __ ] like I said I was
like known before the first episode even
aired I think right but that's what I'm
saying is it's not diegetic Lee
explained within the show it's it
they are allowing this thing to just
unfold so if I if I've never and this
goes back to the conversation we had
last podcast but I'm coming into this
I've never seen a star war then this is
my first introduction into this universe
and I'm going alright so this whole
thing kicks off with this dude who can't
take off his helmet and his little
Muppet so I what I found interesting
about this is that it doesn't go there
is there for the first Star Wars thing
ever
there's not the big bombastic music
playing that has this long scroll
beforehand it's just dropping you and I
was like I enjoy that thank you very
much for that because I wrote one didn't
have that right no rogue one didn't know
right and I didn't see Han Solo so I
don't know if it did that either the
trilogy's the proper Skywalker
pertaining movies yeah I think well for
what it's worth if I may you me
regarding your comment of the dyad usus
missus he when when the Mandalorian gets
the Verner Hertzog order he makes some
comment to Carl Weathers about like
there's Imperials here and he says
something like but they're the Empire is
dead and gone so it's it's established
diegetic Lee pretty early that it is
like in the first episode I think that
this is definitely post Return of the
Jedi but they do it in a way that's not
endlessly lame expositional dialogue
patting itself on the back didn't the
empire correct me if i'm wrong and
people are gonna freak out wasn't it
wasn't the second Rise of the Empire
nowhere like it the third iteration of
the Empire wasn't there like an empire
before and then there was there was not
two deaths does too soon
repeating those cycles right now guys I
found this it's like you know a tree a
try I found this in the basement now
this is called a Death Star now you have
a hole before it before you I think we
should try it again they see where the
flaws were I'm if you wanna look at that
though like that's actually not
Alexander the Great
who was Alexander the Great Napoleon and
Hitler all made a mistake and that's
attacking Russia in winter right so I
mean I that's that's an interesting and
that it's where it had held them up I
the reason why I say this is now in
digging my heels in and I could be
absolutely wrong but I kind of want to
believe that this is the child is Yoda
and that we are watching the birth this
could be 300 years before because he was
300 600 years old yeah yeah but whatever
how old was he 300 600 second for a
living maybe he should do that everybody
can do that voice by the way here's
gonna make me throw down on some major
Star Wars nerdiness here no I'm asking
you I'm in earnest I'm asking you how
old was the other one he thought Yoda
was when 900 years old look as good you
will not although interestingly in
Empire Strikes Back when Luke first
meets him he says for 800 years did I
trained Jedi so his math gets all a
little fuzzy by a hundred years and
what's supposed to be a three year
window between films again I'm just I'm
just showing my crew colors here this is
how you get them wet ah sand with I'm
only gonna I'm not usually gonna do this
but I do want to cut off the Star Wars
talk for this episode because we are you
recording this by two weeks so by the
time this episode is actually up it's
because I'll be in Australia and it's
not there's garbage the new movie will
have actually come out and Mandalore II
know it's gonna care about Mandalorian
anymore by that well it not have been
done by then also I think it's ten
episodes over four weeks away yeah so
we're pretty close but I feel like in
January we can do a giant Star Wars
recap okay cool but let's talk about the
Game Awards to talk about video games I
considered that it might be fun let me
know what you guys think I'm just gonna
throw this on you live if I make us as a
group collectively right now within the
next 45 minutes ranked out top five
games of the year
battle it out with no preparation no
preparations that works it's but it's
very close to most award shows right
yeah so then it doesn't count or
fortnight so but here's the thing is is
at least there are nominees right so
you're you're saying of our own or there
are a list that you're choosing gonna be
tough we can also not do that though
like I mean for the game ones itself did
you guys all watch it I know you would
they're Troy but didn't get into the
building no I got in it was just a bunch
of [ __ ] I guess I arrived late I
don't know I think I arrived minutes
after you but like the the the red
carpet was shut down so the normal way
that I go in was was really really weird
and I was met I ended up coming through
the the back of the theater and so I'm
standing there like their little roped
off section and I was it was really cool
because that normally I don't get to see
I got to take in the full breadth of the
show and to Keeley's credit that was the
biggest production he's ever done like
he really exponentially increased the
production value of his show that
amazing opening thing that churches did
that was a beautiful beautiful piece you
know everyone lost their [ __ ] when the
curtain opened up and there's like I
think was a 22 piece orchestra behind
him so it was it was a great way to kind
of kick off the show but I'm standing
there and I'm trying to get like scuse
me man I need to get down to my seat and
the guy looked at me and now he's a
bouncer and I'm standing at the bar that
everyone's trying to get into it he goes
hey man hold on a second you can't go to
your seat because we're on live TV and
it looked at him and I went well we're
not because this isn't TV and it's being
streamed and the entire theater is is
dark and I'm gonna walk to my seat now
and he wouldn't open up the Rope that I
clearly could have just stepped over and
then I looked behind me and like the
Israelites fleeing Egypt there's just
like now 40 people standing behind me
and I'm at the front of line and
everyone's asking the same questions
like can you move can we're trying to
get past mercy so I'm staying there's
like so it's not a good way to kick off
the show and then at one point it did
flash forward to the end the end of the
show I'm standing there and I'm looking
Green Day comes out and everything and
people are just going creating
yeah and I was like we did it Billie Joe
Armstrong become Ronnie Milsap like he
looked like or like Roy Orbison like he
went full bouffant like if yeah if you
do Stu a side-by-side comparison which
if that's his thing that's that's
totally cool but it's like it was weird
because I think everybody won a green
day and they wanted like American Idiot
Green Day seem like such a weird choice
to me everything else in that show made
sense Green Day I was like hold on
everything made sense with the fosston
Furious decision-making that being like
The Closer of the show was a bit of -
can one airplane - Ken yeah I mean I was
also actually the most shocking part to
me was how blade - gun announced which
I'm very excited about but that's what I
feel like you want to talk about I think
I'll talk about yeah all right I mean
that's pretty much all I have to say
that the trailer was really great the
singing is well that like face
contorting singing was amazing were you
were you surprised that they were
announcing it there are you surprised
that the beautiful face of Mike death
becoming up were you surprised that they
were announcing it are you surprised the
present making it why yeah but I mean it
was so critically received or like yeah
it's she's won best performance but I
mean just because that game subject
nature doesn't lend itself well to a
sequel kind of thing so I think it's
like it's a contained story I'll take
more of it because I love it I would
take enslaved to a hundred times over as
well which oh thank you I felt like you
would be an enslaved guy but that's like
a both of those games I absolutely love
but they walk very well by themselves
and wrap up themselves really well I
just I don't know I just didn't expect
hell-blade to to be a thing that they
would even consider pursuing but I'm
very excited about it that was probably
the biggest announcement for me it was
there anything you guys super excited
about
fossum furious a game that was we pulled
it out of the Volga family family I I
don't like the fact that I looked at
that and I went Vin Diesel looks better
in person than he does in that game and
that's that's not that's not good I
here's my issue
and I've said this before publicly I'll
say it here
I really don't worry I respect what Jeff
Keely is doing and he and I have had
long talks about it like what wouldn't
he works incredibly hard he's incredibly
diligent and dedicated to his cause and
he also understands that every show
people like it needs to be better and
he's like I would be the first one to
admit that everyone he makes he wants to
be better than the previous and he can
own his own mistakes he can laugh at the
fact he's like I should not have had a
giant razor dancing on stage that would
I should not have had Doritos sponsor
this so I mean he he understands that
the thing that I if you want to do an
award show and we talked about this on
the dice podcast AAAS podcast if you
want to do an award show and you just
want to recognize people in the industry
do that if you want to create a
spectacle then you do that but to
conflate the two feels that's what
people are all always kind of pushing
against because to me the the Game
Awards megive out it's a bunch of it's
it's III self-contained within a single
night with a bunch of trailers that they
happen to give us some awards to and I'm
not I'm not doubting that the the voting
process for the the way that they choose
people is not I can talk about so you
then talk about because I feel like it's
a very legitimate process of how they
choose people or how that user their
their nominees and how they they make
their final selections everybody thought
that I think that strany was gonna sweep
everything because they know how much
Jeff Keely loves loves ya Jima that yeah
so how did the how did the initial
nominees get chosen because that has
always been mysterious and I didn't know
you're the first person I've ever talked
to that had any kind of insight on that
yeah so the way that I've formatted it
at least it can be imagine different
websites do it differently but you get
given the categories and then you just
list the things that you would vote for
in those categories and then I think you
have to pick five of each category and
then you just submit them so do you have
any sense how many people that's going
out - oh I have no idea but I think it's
it's a few but to be an outlet there are
specific times that I think Jeff
posted publicly before that you have to
comply to so it Contras be youtubers
that have to has to be sort of more
established media does that mean it's
primarily is this kind of like because
you know you have the disparity in the
movie world between there's the Golden
Globes which is the Hollywood Foreign
Press Association Association which is
which is explicitly like journalists and
then you have the Oscars which is the
film and TV or the film Academy the
Motion Picture Academy which is veterans
you know invited only members of the
film industry past and present and so if
what you're saying is true this is
modeled on the more the Golden Globes
where it's actually games journalists
choosing you Game Awards which I've
never known until just now that's what I
believe to be true but I also can't
speak about that confidently I all I
know is that funhouse is on the board
and IGN was on the board and we voted so
I know that other outlets are on the
board as well but I can't actually speak
to that you'd have to ask Jeff I don't I
don't know exactly who else is on it
sure but I know there is a criteria and
you have to submit all the nominations
by certain day at all you won't even be
considered but you can basically
nominate however you like and from but
this year they were really pushing like
vote now like what what categories were
being voted by or seemingly voted by the
public or was that more of just like
here's some agency for you guys we're
gonna go to you know the the popular
vote vote reverses the you know
Electoral College is that cuz we pick
our nominees and submit them and that
ranked in order and then when it goes
out to the public vote I think the idea
is that the public has an input but they
get like a percentage so it is kind of
like an electoral college like they have
less of an influence than the
journalists do because I think if it
were public vote deaths training
probably would have won my game with us
only disco Elysium though I didn't even
hear that given before you so okay yeah
absolutely fantastic game I highly
recommend it but yeah that's an example
of a game that definitely really only
got any recognition because media played
it which is kind of why I think it's
important it's it's not a popularity
contest because the board Israel of
people who by trade have to play all of
these games which means that you do get
a disco Elysium in there
was out awhile - nominated for anything
I don't remember if it was but I mean
that's a game that I feel like the
public hasn't played a lot of control
getting nominated might not have
happened if it weren't journalists and I
mean control is incredible but a lot of
the public we know from IGN announcing
that it was that game and you have no
idea what it is people like what about
it what you're talking about though is I
always see this mirrored in the Oscars
also where you have this disparity
between the the kind of insiders who are
in the know who understand not just the
stuff that's climbing to the top of the
sales charts and so you end up with
movies being nominated for Best Picture
that the vast majority of people have
never seen or even heard of and there's
always this accusation of elitism and
kind of insider [ __ ] going on with
the Oscars and especially when you have
movies like you know Avengers and stuff
that will do circles box office around
all those and gets completely shut out
of the Oscars other than like a visual
effects nomination or a sound design
nomination kind of thing like
transformers is always notoriously like
that where they'll make a gazillion
dollars but the Oscars are like yeah
hell no and there's a and yeah yeah well
that's where it's like it's like I I can
see both sides of that because I can see
the industry express it like okay I'll
use this as an example a lot of
developers I've talked to over the years
and I'm curious Mike if you echo this
tale of tales is a developer that a lot
of developers have looked to and drawn
inspiration from as like these sort of
auteur types that make these weird games
none of which have been particularly
commercially successful but which have a
lot of kind of compelling ideas so you
always see them at the more insider
Industry type thing it is you will often
see them or they'll be talked about but
the general public would have seemingly
no idea who they are
and it's like is that good is that is
that I I'm curious your take on that
kind of thing as from the developer
angle of it I think it I think it always
comes down to what you think awards are
for right like I think I think it's you
know and that's a bigger question I
actually kind of like this balance of
having an
where you've got you know the likes of
disco Elysium can get celebrated can get
shared can find a new audience alongside
a bunch of trailers and commercials that
are definitely gonna like bringing the
audience and are gonna give a more kind
of mainstream and triple-a kind of
angled things so that seems like an
interesting balance to me that seems
like that would kind of work I'm sure
disco Elysium sold pretty well the day
after the course so as a developer I'm
sure they're pretty happy about it and
I'm you know so I I'm cool with it I
don't I think I think awards probably
the most useful thing about them is to
give people visibility on games they
wouldn't have played otherwise and
that's ultimately what it comes down to
I think that's probably the main purpose
that's why I use film awards like the
number of movies I don't hear about
until I see them nominated for an Oscar
and I work my way through that list and
see some things I would have seen
otherwise
it's you know I completely agree that it
depends on the audience oh sorry the
purpose because like I think that Austin
it's an interesting conversation in that
a lot of the time I do feel like games
journalists and people who just play
games don't necessarily align on
perspectives of different things because
you just once you work in an industry
you have just you just have a different
perspective that's that's how it works
you've been doing two studios you have
generally played a lot more games than
the general public you just it's very
difficult to not change that perspective
even if you're trying to represent the
public or trying to review things to
tell general consumers if they should
buy something or not but I feel like
ultimately every different game award we
have because there are so many I think
are ultimately sort of pointless I don't
feel really matters significantly or
means anything especially when that show
does have a hell of a lot of ads in it
it it's the purpose of that is kind of
diluted I feel like I tend to look at
dice is more of a sure thing but I think
it's it's still a fun show to have just
to celebrate the good stuff that people
well and and here's what kind of I'll
push back against that a little bit Mike
you can also probably speak to this
maybe a little bit more intelligently
that I can but at least my experience
has been this the reason why these
things are important is for the reason
that you said for disco Elysium
probably sold very very well on December
6th so III think that a publisher that
may have given up on a title when all of
a sudden out of nowhere it wins a award
it could win the golden joystick game of
the year that gives the publisher the
opportunity to repackage that game as
the game of year edition and the people
are like oh yeah I did hear some buzz
about that or they do a Steam sale or
something else that that allows them a
second window of opportunity to to
capitalize on that revenue which sounds
like a cash grab and what it really is
is a way for that studio that was I've
talked to Studios before where they were
on like the perfect example monolith
monolith was on the verge of shutting
down they were going after 15 years they
were going to close the doors and they
were gonna ship shadow of Mordor and
that was going to be they're gonna
sunset the studio with that title and
then it started winning awards and it
exploded and the next thing they knew
they were able to build a franchise and
the industry was looking at them to be
able to really push the hardware forward
and therefore push developers forward to
be able to really extrapolate some of
the power underneath the hood of those
those consoles and even PC but I think
that there it's it's you look at
Keeley's and you go
it's fun and it's fair and you get Green
Day to come out and you get Vin Diesel
and Michelle Rodriguez to come out and
talk about a game that nobody probably
cares about not not to disparage the
studio that's making it but it's not
like everyone's been clamoring for a
fast and furious title speak for
yourself
and Tim Geddes but the but but the
opportunity for a studio that that very
much could be on the critical point of
shutting down and anywhere from 30 to
300 people or could be seeking
employment to win an award or for even
the department head of those people to
be able to go either to another studio a
better studio or to even go into their
you know president's office and go I
think it's time I get a raise it's
things like that that I think are
important and do make those accolades
for me as an actor it doesn't mean [ __ ]
it doesn't change my work
one bit you think it's great how do you
feel about the fact that when they did
the voice category they basically just
read it off the side of the stage and
they moved on that's that's in keeping
with honestly with with mark hamill
found out that he he lost to Stephen
Merchant over commercial break Damien
Clark who won for handsome Jack I
watched it happen he was on the red
carpet they were like whoa there's
Daymond Clark we definitely interview
him and Senate Damon Clark er nominated
tonight idea hoping when it's like well
you know as any actor you like to get
recognized for your performance and he's
looking at the teleprompter and that
says bracketed hold for response to
winning okay Austin you had a similar
situation as well yeah this was in the
the final year of of the Spike TV VGA s
you know when was when journey came out
and and everything about it was strange
so so journey had gotten nominated for a
Grammy
two days before so I'm told make sure
you're there for the red carpet because
a lot of folks want to talk to you about
that at the VGA s and so I get this text
I think actually was from Keeley saying
like MTV or whatever wants to do a live
on camera with you at you know 6:42 or
whatever black very specifically can you
be there it's gonna be live so you can't
be late and I'm like cool I'll be there
and sure enough so I'm standing there
and the red carpet is winding down cuz
the shows getting ready to start and so
it's like you can see like you know the
guy was working with at the time he's
like just texting kind of
absent-mindedly the red carpets kind of
empty it or starting to empty out
because we're getting ready for the show
and they're asking questions about the
Grammys in blah blah blah and then
someone just appears with like a fake
spike VG monkey goes guess what yeah the
weird crown monkey and they go so guess
what you won and I remember I was like
excuse me they go yeah you won tonight
how does it feel and I was like I feel
like you're very efficient anticlimactic
yeah
and then any of the best part it was it
was like a fake one because then as soon
as they cut the camera they were like
hey we need that back and and because it
was you know like a dummy one for the
stage later I think it's so then I went
and sat in the chair and the whole night
I was just kind of chilling with some
friends and watching the that whole
thing was kind of the battle between
journey and season 1 of The Walking Dead
yeah and and so I mean it was still a it
was still a fine show and all that but
it was one of those weird things of like
being ambushed beforehand and then it's
like wow all these years later they're
still effectively doing that because
everyone was all upset that deaths
stranding won best music before it even
started and there was no real courtesy
shown to music in general despite all
this obsession with check it out the
game music orchestra alive on stage they
spent more time playing a song from the
game than they did recognizing it's
award look I got to VJs back there I got
this stupid silver monkeys back there
and I gave a they recorded a acceptance
speech from me we did it at Naughty Dog
so I mean it's no one knows how to do it
right
BAFTAs does it very very well and then
you have the opportunity or then you
have kind of the opposite of that where
dice can let people just go on and on
and on
Chris judge is you and I were sitting
there together and we're like oh no it
was a long speech I think it was I think
it was 30 minutes it's bad and it was
almost as if he's just telling he's
still going and he's still going yeah it
was a beautiful speech very heartfelt
but but it would also it kind of showed
how understand was kratos Freitag ah for
God of War and he got up and gave it it
was very kind he dragged his co-star up
there for the play d'etre us up there
with him which was beautiful because
they were both nominated and he was
incredibly giving but it felt like he
was giving a Lifetime Achievement speech
he also one rather than character
character so that's where I feel a lot
of times people don't understand what
the categories for and I've been on
committees before too and even the
criteria maybe we can all kind of talk
about this is I think we've been at some
point we've had a seat at that table -
what does best blank mean like it's when
you when you have something that's so
subjective and this is where at me as an
actor I I had to go it's your opinion
man and it doesn't change my work
whatever I did on that stage whatever
did in the booth if you recognize it by
giving me some monkey that doesn't mean
any that doesn't change whether it was
good or bad and the worst thing is to
get an award for something you know was
not your best so because there's no
established criterium I've never
understood and we battled about this
with with BAFTAs before it's like what
does it mean to have a best new game or
best new IP what is it what is that what
do you quantify that with who can speak
to that I mean you've all voted at some
point of other events um we did top 100
games like that's a nightmare because
you have some people in the room who
were trying to rank the games based on
their impact or significance and then
other people in the room who are trying
to rank them on which is better the
conversation between which game is
better portal 1 or portal 2 is so
complicated because portal 1 is
incredibly game in theory portal 2 is
maybe better but portal 1 is here and
the reason portal 2 exists so it's like
just stuff like that is like I don't
know every person has different criteria
for how this stuff works it's so
complicated doing our Final Fantasy
rankings and I was elder rankings at IGN
it was just rooms full of people yelling
at each other no seven is gonna be the
best yes of course yes I feel like the
BAFTAs are actually slightly better
defined now than they used to be and we
there's there's definite like criteria
when you're a judge up after you they
sit you down and they explain exactly
kind of I don't know if any of that's
publicly available but there's
definitely I think more of a formation
around that they've tried to standardize
it which is good but I'm always the kind
of
wild card in all those rooms I'm always
just like I always have very so tarik
taste so I'm always the guy arguing with
the rest of the room and making it so no
one can go home it's great you're a 12
angry man you're like I just want to
vote one more time so if I if my stance
is sort of that I think all game Awards
a sort of pointless especially when
there are so many like because there are
so many different outlets I don't look
at Game of the Year as only the game
Awards because there are so many
different outlets with different boards
with their own different criteria that
there are a million euro what's in
Troy's stance is that it is helpful for
Studios I don't know how I feel about
that ethically for the industry I don't
know how I feel about the idea that a
publisher would greenlight something
just because it won an arbitrary award
how do you feel about that that as a
developer do you have that pressure I
mean I mean it's to me it's a positive
rather than a negative like it's an
additive effect it has I'm someone who's
definitely benefited from it you know
and my games don't make crazy money like
my games are not like you know the
absolute barn storming kind of
Minecrafts of this world I'll probably
never make one of those why do have is a
certain level of kind of for lack of a
less pretentious phrase artistic
credibility and there are publishers who
100% have funded my games just to get
that kudos just because they they know
that if I work on something it will be
thought of in that way so it's a it's a
bankable thing for me it's it's part of
the sale we do rightly or wrongly I'm
sure it's people who who would disagree
with me deserving that but it's where we
are now so it's fine the other thing
that's important as well has been
massive for us has been our voice
casting has been consistently excellent
except one terrible mistake we made on
John wick hags with Troy but other than
that you know I try to talk about as
well by the way I just want that for the
record but we we've never had trouble
casting a game because because Danny won
that BAFTA for Thomas was alone you know
there there are lots of there are lots
of voice actors who want to work with us
because they know we respect actors and
that will help to walk or frankly gal
the way
so they can produce a great performance
so so it helps in that way that's really
cool
in terms of the impact to me it's it's
adjacent to the Metacritic conversation
you know I don't think a team should
ever get a bonus structure based on
their Metacritic I also don't think a
team should get a bonus structure based
on their awards but given the awards are
going to exist I think there is a useful
thing I think what I've never heard it
says negative I've never heard anyone
kind of say well your game was good but
it did that one didn't win any awards
that's never really come up it's always
an additive thing I think it's always a
bonus it's funny that in that vein I did
once get asked during a press interview
if someone ever thought that getting
that journey being nominated for a
Grammy had cost me opportunities huh and
I remember being like how so well
because they thought do you think it it
it kind of put you in a category where
then developers might have thought oh
well we probably can't afford him now
and they just didn't even bother calling
to open a conversation because it's like
it changed the perception of what it is
I do or what it is I you know what my
self value might be or what whatever
they like he's too prestigious for us
yeah and I was one of those where I was
like well obviously I have no idea what
I don't know I have no idea about the
calls that didn't come that may
otherwise have in some alternate
alternate universe but in my experience
it's very much like what Troy was saying
where you if you liked journey or not
that made zero difference and if you are
in in my experience from that point
forward if if we vibe and you're
interested in hiring me for something
it's then that never comes up in
conversation it's like well I was really
on the fence except that she won some
stuff and got nominated for some stuff
and I guess that's kind of the tipping
point and so I guess yeah it's largely
pointless I think in other words the
exposure so I guess that if knowing it
have a hood of you and then they hear of
you because you won that award like
disco Elysium for example if people are
now hearing that hopefully they'll play
it I hope that happens with control as
well that's a benefit a lot of people
play control talking like I thought so
too but then you see the people's
replies to IGN's announcement and it
seems like nobody knows
it's very crazy to made out like even
when they show the character in the
opening role I was like yeah do like
people I felt maybe maybe it was more
like it's it's the band's band right the
that's the I think that's because of
yeah because I mean let you look at the
this remedy and and and and who all is
involved in it and I think everybody
kind of wants why am i drawn up like it
was the same lake to just always be
successful at least I do I I look at him
and and Max Payne Alan Wake were just
those are that I would still I would
still play those games you know right
now
I love the premise of it I didn't like
the execution did you get because to me
the game is punishing oh it is and it
also does that thing that drives me a
little bit nuts to like I loved if I
could have cut Resident Evil 7 in half
the first half of that game is my game
of the year the second half of that game
it does the same thing that quantum
break has problem with that I feel like
a lot of games do where it just makes
you run the gauntlet the end of the game
is fight everyone you fought before but
they're slightly harder and they're all
there and quantum break my that's
quantum break I was like what do you
want to do do you want to do you want to
be a TV show or do you want to be a game
and it never I mean and each kept
getting in the way of each other whereas
you take Max Payne or Alan Wake I never
felt like there was a disconnect and
we're talking like that's ps2 yo so like
there was a lot of opportunities for you
didn't have the fidelity you didn't have
the bandwidth to be able to do a death
stranding or even the control to where
you have all of these demands that you
have to meet because there's there's a
there's a user expectation of fidelity
across the board we forgave a lot of bad
camera that Max Payne clearly has even
though it has one of the coolest cameras
where you can do the bull of vision
everything or the bullet time my I guess
I'm going back to the to the I think des
training similar like I do feel like in
some parts I felt that way about men I
guess all at fault the game gets in its
way which one on you but in dust raining
not as bad as
in pain fan-out pain was like you know I
feel like he was tempered sons of
liberty is that Peace Walker mother
still have four was Sons of Liberty was
four if four is poor is oh god boys fool
so oh my god the Liberty was the kind of
sons of the Patriots no Sons of Liberty
is two four is Patriots so like going
back to like the the the difference
they're coming to get you Mike going
back to like the the the difference
again with with TV and film and by the
way I do not believe that this is a
standard this is a two-part comment but
if an actor gets a Golden Globe an Emmy
or an Oscar there is the next day their
quote changes so there there is a known
standard now by which an agent can go
well they've won an Oscar so they're
their prices now this right there that
automatically equates almost to a scale
like you can you can go down the grid
and see what this means what that number
is may vary according to the actor but
there is a difference when whatever her
name Jennifer Lawrence whatever watch
across and she got her first Oscar the
next day she was getting different
offers right so to your point Austin
well it's like I don't know what offers
I didn't get because oh we can't get her
now she just won an Oscar
Margaret quali nobody knew who she was
she was the girl from the show on HBO
that nobody was watching the leftovers
and now she is the hot ticket so the
actors commodity kind of changes cary
fukunaga who did season one of what was
on the HBO that every subsequent season
was terrible what am I thinking of
Austin
true Trudy tell you true detective you
know he all of a sudden was like the
go-to guy for for being a director so
everybody wants the new hot ticket so I
think you do kind of you lose some of
the smaller projects that you think you
might have you might have gotten just to
get a gig and instead your quality and
not quality or quantity goes down but
you're now doing bigger things the the
fact that Tim Miller Tim Miller should
never have been as big of a director if
he had not done Deadpool the guy I mean
I've worked for Tim Miller for years
because he cut trailers you know four
four four in Hall duty especially is
what the main thing he did and he just
found a really good way to do special
effects very official he was a Steven
Spielberg and in a lot of ways he found
a way to do big-budget movies on a very
small budget and that's how he did
Deadpool people are like well we should
let him do everything now and that
doesn't mean that he wasn't talented I'm
just saying he used to be very very
accessible you hired Tim Miller's
company to do stuff and now he's you
know this I also believe one thing that
I don't want awards to I wish that like
Golden Globes Emmys in Oscars took a
note from like BAFTA or even Keeley's
award or whatever goes or dice Best
Performance I don't care if to say best
male actor in a comedic role
best female in a dramatic series just
best performance period because there's
far too many people and especially in
the games industry that don't get
recognized
we don't have best character modeler we
don't have best lighting we don't have
best we just kind of speaking out to the
very beginning of this awesome you talk
about it's kind of throwing everything
into the audio department that's in
design like Jesus Christ man one of the
best environments put in the best
background we don't have best animation
we don't have best all the things that
really make a game don't get accredited
it just gets game of the year best
design best sound best actor guest
that's it it's it's you know I mean best
directing but I don't even know what
that means because who are you talking
about are you talking about the the game
design and the game director are you
talking about the cinematics director
are you talking like autonomy
used to get the person who has the clout
on stage that's how you get a lot of
times it right but there's not when you
don't have that person like who would
you have given best direction to on the
Last of Us
Neil Jeff and Bruce early yeah but but
Bureau Straley was the game Tom be the
face right now but but Bruce Straley was
the game director know what I mean so it
I don't well I can tell you that go
ahead the audio the game audio community
internally tries to address that through
what's called the gang awards the game
audio Network Guild Awards which is an
organization that basically every game
composer audio director sound designer
you know dialogue editor recording
engineer there's a there's a group and
they do it during GDC and so the game
audio network Guild Awards are trying to
kind of address that where they have you
know their grand category is audio of
the year and it's basically like a
team's
collective efforts but there's also
separately sound sound design of the
year music of the year and then it gets
even more granular from there where they
have a you know best instrumental
composition best best use of choir
versus best song production they have
best dialogue they have best you know
they have best interactive
implementation they have best soundtrack
album they have best article best like
article about game audio because there's
a whole area of sheezus gradualism and
this is max best craft services and
they're recording 6 of 5 hour long so
yeah I think quality one sound and I
feel like when that was they said that I
just always do the thing where I guess
what its gonna be and one more fair was
one of the ones that I picked did not do
do you really yeah it's incredible the
snow design in that game is nuts but
there's just one thing it's just they
put six microphones on every gun and
it's it's not like that I necessarily
paid a lot of attention to the school
while playing it it's just that when I'm
talking about someone's footsteps or the
way a gun sounds I'm like yeah that
keeps incredible but it doesn't there's
so much that doesn't encompass
for sure in a way that it's like there's
a whole team of people they've got
ripped I mean games have a DS now games
have people who are deciding what did
the framing is for a character to make
them look the right amount of oppressed
or how much grain there is or if it's
cool or it's warm in a certain shot
there are so many things even films have
awards for that games don't because I
don't know man everyone underestimates
how hard games are to make that's my hot
tech it's really guys I I feel like I
feel like we've kind of proven that any
kind of voter theory is nonsense and
basically only useful for marketing yeah
but I do feel like I'm a little
uncomfortable with Game Awards and me
being on a board that if the whole
purpose of it is marketing I'm a little
uncomfortable with it but I don't know
I'm willing to feed that beast if it
means that a game gets made that's
that's that's yeah that the second that
if marketing wants to use that and be
able to again if the studio is going to
benefit from it did fine I'll have
Doritos and a razor dancing across the
stage if it recognizes people that's one
thing that I've tweeted out as soon as
the words were over and everyone was
like immediately fighting over whether
deaths training got robbed resting you
know nobody can tell you who your game
of the year is you have to tell you you
decided that is for you right because
there's there's other games that came
out that didn't get nominated there I'm
sure people were like it's just your
opinion man but if it does recognize
celebrate and reward the countless hours
that people back at a studio spend to
ship that game then I'm all for all of
the awards even even Sony I was down at
Sony's two studios and they had an
internal they calm the bad ass Awards
and it's just for within the people
there and they're like we want to
recognize what you did and one of the
awards they were giving I like the guy
said it was no doubt that destiny was a
very very hard game to ship and they're
giving out awards for accounting people
that worked in accounting they're giving
a whirl I was like there you go man
and it's everyone goes outside they and
and they you know they drink wine and
IPAs and they they get pissed together
and have a good night that that's what
I'm
I support it doesn't necessarily have to
be green day up on a stage it doesn't
have to be a celebrity walking across to
give an award to another celebrity but I
do believe that recognition can be
valuable as long as the people that are
receiving the awards are benefiting from
it other than just getting a pedigree I
think as well the the extra layer on
that is having celebration in general
like beyond the individuals and even the
games in particular is massively
important it's important to just spend a
night a year just celebrating the video
games are awesome and that they exist
and we that we there's big benefits of
amyl leaves I really am NOT a fan of the
what the point Troy made a little while
ago about the kind of weird
cross-pollination of III and an award
show because to me to me the the what
what Mike just said is so crucial let's
celebrate the awesomeness of games and
to me when that takes on the
self-reflective nature of this past year
we all did the following things
collectively as an industry and we you
know we bent over backwards people you
know had blood sweat and tears in order
to ship these things if it's like but
wait hold on
coming right what you want to see yeah
to me it's like winning pointing
backward is way more emotionally
meaningful to me in that context than
the hype of looking forward and it to
the point that it's almost disrespectful
to the struggle of all those people and
never mind the hundreds of games that
didn't make it to that final night you
know and be nominated amongst amongst
those titles to me so the Phil Spencer
can announce that there's gonna be a new
Xbox yeah like my I remember my my agent
once that we developed your skies well
because and also to your actually to
your point Troy a minute ago also you
you said about like can this get a game
shift and then when you were talking
about actors quote you know after an
Oscar I think that a lot of that is also
uniquely true for actors relative to
basically any other category because
actors have a unique responsibility to
be the face of the marketing in many
cases sure not just
talent that is on screen as part of the
consumption of the process there are a
major force in selling it even in even
in games right and so I mean you know
that better than any of the rest of us
here so I think that that that's because
I'm agent has this whole trivia of like
I'm gonna name composers you've never
heard of and what they all have in
common is they've all won Oscars is
because if you're if you score something
that happens to be hot but your career
is not otherwise on that trajectory no
amount of winning Oscars is going to
matter if you're not someone that the
industry is all collectively going
towards then then it doesn't it's
irrelevant and you become a trivia
contest winning winning question but but
the way that he phrased it once my my
agent Richard once said this beautiful
thing where he goes imagine that your
great passion in life is baking pies
because you loved giving pies to your
friends and your family and it's like
you you spend all this time obsessing
over how do i gelatinize the fruit
perfectly and how long to bake the crust
and bla bla bla bla bla and you really
dial it in and get really damn good at
it and then one day on a whim you submit
it to a pie-making contest and then you
realize what makes your family happy and
what makes the pie judiciary happy are
not the same thing and so if you have
these this is this is this judged by a
jury of Pi journalists or acknowledged
hires this is a jury of very rotund and
rubenesque pie aficionados and okay I
think what happens is you if you start
cake like making pies to win pie Awards
you started changing not only have you
forgotten why you were doing it to begin
with but you're also making them through
a kind of artificial criteria like the
kind of the kind of score that wins Best
Original Score often kind of fits under
a few sort of cliches and we don't tend
to take seriously like you mentioned
Call of Duty that's a great example
where Sarah Shatner scored Modern
Warfare she also scored infinite warfare
before that and like those are very
often overlooked because it's like no no
no the serious scores are you know
the the like indie darling types or the
big lush orchestral types you know like
Jedi fallen order or something and
meanwhile she's over there just crushing
it with this wall of analog synths and
all manner of amazing of course there's
also Orchestra in there too but like I'm
like the fact that you can almost
guarantee that a score like that will
not be taken seriously it shows that
there is a kind of there's a kind of
because it's oncology Tudor I didn't
notice the skull that much in that game
and no you're right it's know especially
with games I think it's a little more
complicated because there are some games
we don't want to take seriously for
those kind of odds and I feel like FIFA
yeah that same thing is like adventures
I will say for for Ludwig that guy
worked his ass off he really really did
too and that was the first thing that he
was talking about he's like I have a
vision for what this what the soundscape
wants to be he worked really really hard
on the music he stretched himself as a
musician as a composer and as a game
maker as well so he and and for him to
get that moment and to share that moment
I've been like I was so nervous and he
got to be up on stage and accept that
award
even though as before he's still got to
have that moment and those are moments
that I want award shows to craft a
nekoma name those are like deathbed I
want this to be in the highlight reel
that I did I did this and and the when
the actor director composer whomever it
is sitting there in the middle of crunch
at 3 o'clock in the morning and they've
just called there's their partner and
said I'm not gonna be home when I
thought it was I'm sorry and they sit
there and they stare at a screen and
they go why the [ __ ] am i doing this
what am i giving my life over what PI am
i baby
um I do want those moments of them going
it's this this is why you're doing it
something that was difficult and felt
pointless special and just but just it
doesn't have to be it doesn't have to be
in an award show you know I I feel like
instead I'm sorry I can't push back a
little it's just different to you all
choice just said oh sorry
no that's alright I was just saying this
could go out to your peers as well along
especially is understanding that you
could be their award show you you could
say hey listen I really this person
didn't like if dis colesium didn't win
Best narrative you saying I really feel
it like you called it before I really
feel that this game deserves this that's
out of wild and concrete Jeannie
specifically concrete Jeannie grated
yeah not because it's like I think that
those games are my caring game in my
game of the is Sakura but it's just that
I feel like they were underlooked but
just very very good games so it's yeah
that's that's part of the point is that
outlets we have the opportunity to
champion those smaller games every year
all the time and one of the things that
I always felt very passionately about
that IGN was okay with me doing was you
do something that will get a lot of use
and for every three of those things
which is what you do you know that's
your job is to create content that
traffic's you would be allowed to write
a passion piece if you wanted it's not
that mathematical but if I were to write
a piece about why I thought concrete
Cheney is a beautiful heartwarming game
and everyone should play it that's not
gonna traffic well but IGN was always
like absolutely you're allowed to write
it like they wouldn't stop you from
writing things and there are other sites
that I have pitched things to about
concrete geni even this year for example
and out of wilds that have been like
it's not gonna traffic we can't let you
publish that and I think that's hugely
IGN's critic that they will let you talk
about the small things that nobody will
read all maybe five people will read who
will hear about a game that they
otherwise wouldn't have heard of so I
appreciate I want to hear Mike I want to
hear Mike's dick devil's addressee hit
us with it oh I was gonna I was yes it
was
Troy talking about being recognized and
getting recognition I was just gonna say
that I think I think that's cool and I
think that's often something people need
but also I'm definitely someone who
wants to try and push myself towards
more intrinsic motivation and extrinsic
it's definitely earlier on in my career
I definitely was like really wanting the
plaudits and the great reviews and the
awards and all that stuff and definitely
as I'm aging I'm finding I'm trying I'm
trying to focus more on being happy with
my work for the sake of working so just
gonna push a bit back against that I
think I think
extrinsic motivation can can turn sour
as well I know piya yeah plenty of my
peers in the indie space like who've who
struggled you know where the game hasn't
been received well who or you know
they've they've they've they felt
something went differently than they
hope that kind of thing and it's it's
kind of can be heartbreaking so I'm
trying to kind of force myself not to
pay as much attention to those extrinsic
I think that sounds Troy yeah sure I
think that if you are seeking that
seeking being lauded you're never gonna
get what you want and you're gonna
you're never gonna get it you're
constantly going to be if you're chasing
after that and say will you recognize me
for what I've done all I'm saying is
that I I believe that there is for those
people that little big I'm sure he
wanted that moment but I don't think
that we have to have someone walk across
this stage and to get a monkey in order
to just guy really appreciate what you
did what I hope to do is is raise
awareness for people who have a laptop
and an opinion to be able to go
understand that your words really do
matter because whether or not you feel
that they should have an impact there's
a publisher behind that does look at
that Metacritic whether that should be
the case or not there is a publisher
that looks at whether you did or did not
win awards and maybe we looked and maybe
not do this game again I was this week I
got there's a game that I've been
attached to for a year in production
shut down didn't make the culling really
yeah cuz somebody looked at and they
were like nope and was like we've
already shot on this game they've been
in the production they've rewritten
stuff and they they they shut it down
it's the nature of the business now
those talented people I'm hoping they
don't shutter the studio and they just
go look ghost was not sucker-punches
first thing after infamous second son
they've gone through multiple iterations
and presented multiple iterations to
Sony they worked really really hard on
that title we don't always get it right
out of the gate and fortunately Sony's
incredibly patient publisher but they're
not always like that so what I'm simply
saying is well I don't believe that you
should chase those accolades we who are
potentially able to give those accolades
should be more more reticent to
criticize and more ready to to to praise
and to encourage if we reach the
consensus that yeah we have a lot of
issues with the way award shows are
conducted and I definitely do but I feel
like for the most part if people are
being celebrated I would prefer that
they exist then not exist so we are
running out of time though so I have
already presented my game in the it is
Sakura what's everyone else's just to
make that quick your favorite game for
me telling lies okay really easy we're
gonna get in that whole conversation I I
was actually gonna say telling lies also
but with the giant caveat that I will
have a vastly more informed answer to
this in a couple of weeks because I've
been plowing through a backlog of games
there's a bunch like I still haven't
even played control I've had it
installed since the day it came out
because it's the kind of game I
typically love but I just haven't had
actually like that game
I have my suspicions that I'm gonna I
certainly love quite a lot of of Sam
lakes body of work and this gun seemed
right is great and so oh yeah I was
stoked but it was one of those that I
remember I was so the other Sam mr.
Barlow I was so enamored of her story
and I remember thinking when I saw the
initial trailers for telling lies I
remember thinking you know it looks like
it's basically the same formula and the
novelty of what of her story was such a
big part of what made it so enjoyable
that I have a hard time believing that
telling lies could do anything other
than just remind me of how good it was
the first time he tried it and to his
credit he actually because of the the
nature of the the fact that everything
is a conversation and not a monologue
that's so radically altered the
experience for me just that one detail
alone that I was like holy hell he
actually did manage to get out from
under his own shadow and do a game that
I think is probably the better of the
two
for sure the reason I actually sorry go
ahead like I said have you gone back and
so I went back and played her story
Austin because I wanted to kind of test
that theory no I haven't an her story
yeah definitely is nowhere near as good
as telling lies like you can definitely
see that progression which is nice
still obviously a very good game but
like it's nice to see that yeah the the
process Sam and his team have kind of
gone through it's it's getting better
yeah the reason that I didn't play
telling lies is because I played her
story and I was like I think I have
experienced this thing but I guess I
screwed up well I'm going to build upon
what what Austin said and I don't feel
that I I'm capable of giving my winner
for game of the year because I've
started and stopped and not completed
and that's that's a perfect example of
like I started yeah I started it to me
it's like how can you say it's you know
that it's an Oscar winning film if you
walked out at the end of Act two you
need if you need to see it at its
entirety so people like yeah I played a
little bit of this and got an idea you
passed the train and falling in order at
least not yet I'm still scream because I
I started playing telling lies and to me
in the very beginning is like alright
this doesn't feel iterative enough and
that it's not or innovative enough and
and it just kind of the building upon I
enjoyed her story for the same reason
that you're saying that Austin so for
that what I'm looking forward to is we
start to shut down at the end of the
year here even though I know this is
probably gonna go over the future is
being able to actually go back and and I
I feel like oh it to that's why it's so
hard for me to start a new game a lot of
times it's because I don't I don't want
to start unless I know I can't finish it
a little bit yeah because of the way I
think I'm doing a disservice
now even though like you look at the
percentage of people that actually
finished games and it's it's 60 percent
is incredibly hot so what I'm looking
forward to is actually being able to
come back to you guys next time and be
able to say hey I finished this and this
is my god I mean I didn't stranding
I haven't finished out of Wilde's but I
have such like that game specifically I
just think is so incredible that I want
to tell everyone to play so in theory we
finish outer worlds Hitler shows up I
liked I liked outer worlds that was a
weekend binge for me it was a friend of
mine said you know if you liked fallout
its space fallout and that's not wrong
and but I I definitely enjoy it I think
that's hilarious Lee the whole notion of
it like starting it or not I have played
I think six hours of death stranding and
I still feel like I haven't even the
same way I think I've probably played
like maybe 10 and I feel like I've
played one because that games so broad
that there's so much to experience but I
think that's to its credit and like that
about it see I'm not sure I think that
that is to its credit that after six
hours I'm still being told just give it
more time I promise and I'm like but
that's the lie that's what keeps
bringing me back as I've been that guy
who has said just get through season one
I promise it picks up in season 2 there
are so many of my favorite shows that's
true for that it feels very hypocritical
to look at death stranding and say look
I've already given this thing six or
seven hours of my life and I just it's
not grabbing me as much as I want to
because it's not a passive experience
you have to interact with it constantly
like I don't think it's quite the same
as television in that regard but I mean
that the Final Fantasy arguments one
that I always think is really funny with
I think it's 13 or 13 to people like
you're just gonna put 13 what unforgiven
yeah well I'll leave it there with you
guys a lot of you have an amazing flight
yeah happy Holidays to you guys next
month because this is a monthly podcast
about star was probably I'm seeing it
with my mom and my stepdad yeah for a
midnight opening yeah screening I have
not seen any of the other films it's a
good another wonderfully lost wait so
who is this Luke Skywalker that they
keep talking about I don't know why that
would be what my Australian family
sounds like what I always promise you I
was going
go there but I jus just old just old
never wait of them I love that it's like
just becoming this sort of Upper East
Side Jewish you put it there all right
back kill all right well then we will
return next month to make it the Star
Wars podcast exactly what podcast
services I'm gonna put the show up on
yet but it'll be up on iTunes for sure
I'll try and get it on everything but if
anyone who's watching has any requests
for where they want to listen to the
audio version of the show now that we
have a cool title and a logo I can see
if I can put it up on all those so just
totally let me know and I'll be flexible
about where it publishes but yeah uh
we're on the last Friday of every month
so check us out next month and we'll be
right back here